i'd go knock on his door
and i'd say john let's have us a
michelob ultra
and i would talk to him
and i'd do whatever it takes i'd put my
ego aside and say hey the best thing for
you is to stay right here
you know make concessions do whatever it
takes do not lose that player
look i understand what jimmy johnson's
saying i have a feeling he'd be drinking
both michelob ultras if he was david
culley because deshawn's not answering
the door you're not going to get him at
this point you're not going to get him
to talk to you at this point beer's not
going to do it nothing is going to do it
at this point i understand the
importance of keeping him but that's
something detection should have taken
into consideration before they poisoned
the relationship to the point where he
wants out so what shereen williams and i
are going to do we're going to put
together proposed trade packages for
deshaun watson specific teams specific
terms sharing i'll let you go first with
your
number one trade possibility
well we know that deshaun watson wants
to play for robert saller or we think
that right because he wanted the texas
to talk to robert sala so the jets makes
sense and he also makes sense
because
it's a big market team and we know he
wants the marketing deals and he sees
that as a good place to go for himself
he does have the no trade clause so it's
going to be a little bit up to him in
where he goes
i think carolina for instance is going
to be a big player in this if the texans
truly are listing the offers and i think
they're a great offer but i don't know
that deshaun watson is going to want to
go to carolina even though he did play
at clemson i think the jets make the
most sense because of all those reasons
and because of the draft capital that
they have so i'm going to propose the
trade of quinn and williams sam darnold
even though he might not long term be
their quarterback he could at least be a
bridge quarterback their first rounder
the number two overall pick in which
they could use that on the second best
quarterback in this draft a third round
pick this year the number 66 overall
pick and a first rounder in 2022 as
compensation for desean watson i think
that is a pretty good deal for both
teams look for wherever he goes mike
it's going to hurt it's going to hurt
that team where he goes because it's
going to cost a lot to get desean watson
out of houston
well and see that's the challenge for
deshawn watson you want out but there's
a sweet spot there of how much your new
team gives up to get you because you
don't want to jump from one four and
twelve team to another four and 12 team
because they've mortgaged too much of
the future and or the present to allow
you to be successful if i'm the texans
though because my first proposal same
two teams texans jets if i'm the texans
i don't want your your semi failed
former first round pick although quinton
williams came on pretty well late last
year i want draft capital i want to do
what the browns did a few years ago
where they tore it down and acquired as
many draft picks as i possibly can i
want the third overall pick i want the
first round pick that the jets got for
jamal adams and i want next year's jets
first round pick not the second jamal
adams first round pick i want those
three picks that's the price of
admission to even continue the
discussion with me you got to come to
the game with three first-round picks
then
we'll see how much more you may have to
throw onto the pile because i'm going to
try to set up an auction between you and
maybe another team in your division but
three first round picks minimum and then
you twist the teams that come with three
first round picks for another whether
it's a third rounder second round or
whatever it may be to get the deal done
so i don't want your players if i'm the
texans i want your picks all right
shireen what's your second proposal well
and i have players in this proposal too
mike but i think that the texas would
much prefer to have him go to an nfc nfc
team we have no doubts about that if
they're going to trade and get him to
the nfc don't let him beat you in the
afc year after year after year because
that's what he would do so i'm going to
say san francisco 49ers because i think
that'd be a place that he might want to
go he would agree to go to
give me jimmy garoppolo give me jeff
wilson because he just signed a
restricted free agent tinder he's not
going to cost all that much or an
extension i want fred warner your best
linebacker because he is a playmaker on
defense we know that then i want your
first rounder this year which is number
12 overall i want your first rounder
next year and i want your second rounder
in 2023.
yeah look at that that makes sense as a
destination if i'm the 49ers though
i think psychologically it becomes very
difficult to trade that much stuff
for a guy you could have had they could
have had desean watson they didn't do
the homework on desean watson and
patrick mahomes or any of the
quarterbacks in the 2017 draft because
kyle shanahan thought he was getting
kirk cousins via free agency in 2018. so
my proposal number two would be
to the miami dolphins
same idea give me back my first round
pick which is third overall that went to
the dolphins as part of the larry
laramie tunsil trade and i want at least
two more first round picks your other
earned first round pick this year and
your first round pick next year to get
to the table to get to the auction
between you and the jets because this
this is a way
that
nick casario can undo
a lot of the dysfunction you play this
the right way you get the dolphins
pitted against the jets and they start
you know bidding higher and higher and
higher to get the guy
and to keep him from going to the other
team now i also don't want tuatanga by
loa because i'm not sold on tuatanga by
loa i'll get my quarterback somewhere
else i don't want tua maybe i'll get
matthew stafford maybe i'll find someone
else but i don't want to toggle by loa i
want draft capital
three first round picks plus whatever
else i can squeeze out of you as i pit
the dolphins against the jet shireen
and it'd be a good way to rebuild mike
because they don't have drop cap draft
capital they don't have cap space
they're a long way from contending even
if they do keep the sean watson which
leads me into
the texas are going to mess this up
somehow some way we've seen it
so i'm not even going to go for a third
trade scenario i'm going to say they're
going to try to hold on to him they're
going to wait until after the draft
which is a huge mistake if you're going
to trade him you have to do it before
the draft because you have to get a
quarterback and you have to figure out
what you're going to do for your future
it has to be before the graph but i
think they're going to mess this up to
the point of it's going to be after the
draft they're going to sit on it they're
going to think they can talk him into
coming back well he has a contract he's
coming back of course he's coming back
we said he's coming back and he's not
going to come back so i see them messing
this whole thing up mike and maybe
trading them at some point in training
camp or into the season and not getting
the fair market value that they should
have gotten
i i think that uh that is far more
likely than the scenario i'm about to
propose that they will screw it up and
he will be there and maybe they end up
trading him at the deadline to someone
for a lot less than they could have
gotten in march
i've got a crazy three teamer in mind
which would involve desean watson being
traded to the patriots
and matthew stafford being traded
to the texans so the texans would get
stafford
the patriots would send a first-round
pick
to the texans
a first round pick
to the lions to get stafford to
houston plus
some other pick second round third round
now you're not getting your three first
round picks that way but you are getting
matthew stafford and the lions are
getting a one for matthew stafford but a
three-team deal where the pats get
deshawn watson bill belichick and nick
casario work together to craft this
thing that they then sell to brad holmes
and the detroit lions it gets the texans
a quarterback it gets the patriots a
quarterback it keeps watson from the
jets or the dolphins and it allows
belichick and caserio to renew
acquaintances that's crazy enough that
it's probably more likely than a simple
deal but i could see some sort of a
three-team trade here shireen because
you want if you're the texans to get a
quarterback you don't necessarily want
sam darnold or tuatong of iloa
yeah or if you're gonna get a high draft
pick mic you want that high draft pick
you know two three four range so that
you can get a young quarterback that you
hope develops into desean watson but
mike the problem for the texas is when
you look at those teams with those high
picks they're all afct
yeah that's right and you're gonna have
to deal with the possibility that desean
watson isn't leaving the conference but
you know nick casario needs to spend
every hour of every day thinking about
trade scenarios and uh feel free to take
our advice nick you're guaranteed to get
your money's worth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports